TICKET CLERK: Deck 7,
departing in two minutes.
JULES VAUGHN:
Thank you.
♪ (SLOW MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
RUE BENNETT: Jules,
I just realized that
I didn't bring my medication.
JULES: We can get medication,
like, everywhere.
RUE: Yeah, but I don't think
it's something that
I can, like, miss a day.
You know?
JULES: Rue, we'll figure it out.
I promise.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
Jules, I don't-- I don't think
this is a good idea.
Rue, it was your idea!
I know-- I know it was my idea,
but I just--
I don't think it's a good idea
anymore.
That's why I'm trying
to tell you.
(CHUCKLES)
It was a fucking great idea.
I don't know
what you're talking about.
Can you slow down
'cause I'm thinking,
you know, my mom.
I don't want her
to fucking freak out, all right.
I don't want to do it.
Rue, it's not that far and,
like, we're good.
We can-- we can call.
What am I gonna tell Gia though?
Like, she's gonna wake up
in the fucking morning.
She's gonna think I'm missing.
We're good. Come on.
It's gonna be amazing.
Rue!
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
(VOICE CRACKING) Come on.
Please come.
I love you.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪